قال رئيس حركه حماس في الخارج خالد مشعل
ان اسرائيل وفي ظل فشلها في غزه تحاول
تصدير الازمه الى الخارج مضيفا ان اغتيال
الاحتلال لقيادات حماس وغيرها من الفصائل
لن يزيد المقاومه الا تمسكا وثباتا لان
الشعب الفلسطيني لا ينكسر على حد
تعبيره في ظل فشله وارتباكه وتضاعف خسارته
في جنوده اليوم يريد ان يصدر ازمته الى
الخارج يريد ان يوصع دائره العدوان ظنا ان
ذلك يربك حسابات المقاومه وحسابات المنطقه
وظن ايضا ان اغتياله للقاده سيكسر اراده
المقاومه وسيضع القياده وما علم ان ذلك
وهم كبير لقد جربه لو كان يعقل لقد اغتال
العشرات والمئات بل الالاف من قيادات
شعبنا طوال العقود الماضيه من كل الفصائل
ومن حماس تعلمون على راس القائده الشيخ
احمد ياسين المؤسس من كانت النتيجه كلما
ترجل قائد نهض قائد واستشهاد قائد يولد
قيادات اخرى بذات الطريق بذات الاراده
بذات الاصرار فهذا شعب عظيم